yes so welcome to better algorithm
intuition as mentioned or just mentioned
my name is Connor Hoekstra I go by code
underscore report on Twitter and just
right off the top of this talk if you
find it easier to follow along on your
laptop or on your cell phone you can go
to either of the two links listed here
so the one below is a tiny URL that's
tiny dot CC / 2q d LG z that's all in
lowercase but note that if you are
following along on your phone or on your
laptop there are spoilers in this talk
so try to really pace with me and don't
go ahead and if you accidentally do go
ahead please refrain from answering any
of the questions in this talk is that
that'll be cheating so I like to start
off each of my talks with the following
quote I'm not an expert I'm just a dude
and that's from Scott sure who gave a
talk at CPP Con 2015 if you if you have
an answer for me because I'm not an
expert I'm just a dude if you have an
answer for me or if you have questions
or whatever else not only do you get to
ask your question or make your statement
but you also get chocolate so I'm
stealing the quote and I'm also stealing
the gimmick so I might wait till the end
if people are lining up or queuing for
questions because I don't think I can
throw all the way to the back but I have
some polish candies here which are very
delicious so if you ask or answer a
question either during the presentation
or at the end you will receive a wawel
candy so a little bit more about me some
of this was covered in the introduction
I'm a senior library software engineer
and I work for NVIDIA I work for a rapid
team as mentioned that's a end-to-end
data science on the GPU very exciting
it's all open source if you're
interested in contributing or checking
it out go to rapid not AI I'm a
programming language enthusiast so I've
primarily developed in C++ and I've been
doing that for just over five years but
I also take interest in many other
programming languages
I love auto I'm in the triple-a Auto
Club that's almost always auto I also
prefer East Const I love algorithms and
I'm super excited to be here today
talking to you about the algorithms in
the algorithm header and I also have a
YouTube channel where I solve
competitive programming problems in a
variety of languages primarily in Java
C++ and Python and I utilize different
algorithms in solving these problems so
if you're interested in checking that
out you can just google code report on
YouTube so I gave a prequel to this talk
called algorithm intuition at both C++
now and CPP Khan if you haven't checked
that out and you enjoy this talk be sure
to go check this out I would recommend
the C++ now one it's a little bit
shorter and I think it's the better
version of the talk but in these two
talks I gave a 10 to 15 minute
motivation for why I'm giving this talk
I'm not going to go through that 10 to
15 minute motivation but I'm gonna give
an abridged version and it started with
a talk that was given by Shawn parent in
2013 at a conference called going native
and the title of the talk was C++
seasoning in that talk
he said now famously this rotate and he
proceeded to say it a few more times
throughout that talk
that's a rotate that's a rotate that's a
rotate that's rotate the rotate rotate
the rotate because rotate rotate rotate
when rotate rotate rotate rotate rotate
rotate rotate and rotate rotate rotate
rotate rotate and a rotate rotate is a
very common operation
that's a rotate so as you can tell Shawn
parents a big fan of rotate but more
importantly he said in that talk the
following so you have all these
algorithms at your disposal right learn
them it's very important so this was
back in 2013 and this led to a wave of
other individuals referring back to this
talk and referencing this and talking
about how you should learn those
algorithms that includes martial Clow
Kate Gregory Odin Holmes and Jonathan
Baqarah is using standard algorithms
because he knows the algorithms we need
to know oh yes should go looking
algorithm learn your algorithms and
those clips combined with the following
quote from a CPP cast episode and Jason
Turner's in the front row one of the
co-hosts of that podcast motivated this
talk just as you can say that would be a
good use of a linked list we don't have
that intuition about algorithms yet and
we need to so all of that combined with
that clip led to this talk and the
prequel to this talk so the goal of this
is to hopefully get you excited about
algorithms hopefully you'll learn a new
algorithm and hopefully to start to
develop some intuition about these
algorithms and how to use them for
certain problems so we're gonna start
with a prologue and it's referring back
to the sequel the prequel to this talk
where we covered the algorithms in the
numeric header so I showed this table
where basically we have the three sort
of algorithm headers algorithm new
American memory and in the prequel talk
I covered algorithms that were in the
numeric header in this talk we're gonna
be focusing on algorithms from the
algorithm header note that there is 87
up to and including C++ 17 there's no
way we're going to cover them all I'm
gonna focus on about 20 to 25 of them
but that's it's good to know and note
that there is a hundred eleven
algorithms in total and recently at the
previous Belfast ISO meeting an
individual by the name of Vincent Rivera
T plotted this really nice histogram at
least in my opinion because I love
algorithms of the length of all of the
algorithm names so the number of
characters in each algorithm and along
with this he also posted the following
what I call Vincent list which is
basically the number of characters to
the left of each algorithm name and
importantly what he said was that there
was a hundred and fourteen algorithms in
this list which is not the same as the
111 that I counted and I got really
concerned because previously I had sort
of disavowed what Jonathan Baqarah said
when he said that there was a hundred
and five algorithms in those three
headers and so I needed to make sure
that it wasn't 114 and it was 111 and
there are three algorithms in this list
there's no way you can read it but I
thought it was useful to point it out
lexicographical three-way compare is a
C++ 20 algorithm so the algorithms that
I had posted are up to and including C++
17 and then there's two algorithms here
that are not in the algorithm numeric or
memory headers and that is a Q sort and
B search those are in these C stood Lib
headers so 111 up to and including C++
17 is definitely the case and there's
another thing that I want to point out
while we're talking about all the
algorithms is that and they talk that
Kate Gregory gave back at the CPP con
2019
she said the following there's a little
algorithm header love Club which has had
meetings this week out to say and you
know you know who we are I heard this
and I was like what there's a little
algorithm header love Club
I love algorithms and not
not a part of this club so I went and
looked and sure enough there is an
algorithm love club you can join at
algal love club they've got just over a
hundred followers and you know their
handle is algo underscore love
underscore Club if you love algorithms
and you want to join the club know that
it exists I was extremely surprised when
I when I heard about this seeing as I've
given now this is my second talk on
algorithms and I had no idea this Club
existed so if you're interested in
joining you can follow there so that
brings us to chapter one so the first
two chapters and the fourth one are
gonna focus on leet code problems so
raise of hands who's familiar with leet
code or I've heard of it at least that
is about maybe 10% or less of the
audience so leet code is a website that
typically students or individuals used
to prepare for technical interviews for
large companies because they asked very
similar questions in their interviews so
I'm gonna take a handful of problems
from this website and they're gonna be
solvable by STL algorithms in the
algorithm header note that for the first
chapter each of these is all solvable by
a single algorithm so these are supposed
to be pretty easy hopefully everyone's
gonna get them in the crowd I'm gonna
show the problem I'm gonna read it if
you know the answer just shout it out
and and then we'll move on from there so
chapter one reverse or write a function
that reverses a string so yes I've heard
10 to 20 people yell out stood reverse
and at this point you might be thinking
wow I went to the wrong talk this is
gonna be extremely boring I promise that
it's gonna get more exciting as the talk
goes on oh and I should also note that
in the bottom left hand corner over here
you can see that the analog algorithms
in the thrust library which is the STL
library for CUDA sort of the similar as
STL algorithm library is for c++ so if
you're interested in GPU development you
know you can look at the PDF for this
which is on my github and this will
hyperlink you to the documentation for
that so getting back to the reverse
problem you might be thinking this is
very easy everyone probably knows this
in the room why am i showing it well for
every leak code problem on that website
you have a forum where people get to
post their solutions and you can filter
it by whatever language you want and so
here I'm showing the
C++ solutions let's take a cut a look at
a couple of them this is the the number
one solution I'm about to show 25,000
views for C++ I'm not gonna repeat a few
of the things I heard from the crowd but
yes safe to say this isn't what we would
expect as the number one solution let's
take a look at the next top solution
must be some trolling I don't think so I
think people just are not aware of the
STL algorithms let's take a look at
another solution down to two lines we're
using stood swap similar to the first
solution so we're getting closer
this next solution I thought here we go
this is gonna be the one that uses stood
reverse C++ one-liner for those that you
didn't that didn't catch it it's just
the previous solution modified with the
body on the same line as the for
statement or for loop so okay getting
further away and and this was the
solution when I finally saw it I was
like ok this is what I'm looking for one
line C++ code with the help of STL
they're explicitly stating we're using
the SEL here so of course this is gonna
be stood reverse write a string
constructor using reverse iterators it's
not it's not terrible but definitely not
what you expect so the point I'm trying
to show here is that even the simplest
algorithms that all the C++ folks in the
room know there's you know for every one
person in this room I'm sure that
there's you know insert number thousands
out in the wild that don't know about
the simple algorithm so I think it's
worth reviewing the ones that we
consider the simple ones so that brings
us to our second problem implement a
function to lowercase that has a string
parameter STR and returns the same
string in lower case I heard it one
person most people said to lower but the
out that's not specifically an algorithm
the algorithm we're looking for is stood
transform with two
so yeah this is pretty straightforward
you're basically just passing to
iterators to define the range and an
output iterator which is just going to
be the same as the string that we passed
in with the first two iterators and then
the two lower is gonna do two lower for
each character
next problem or I think we're actually
gonna look at the Haskell solution here
indeed we are
map is the equivalent of transform in
Haskell this doesn't really do anything
for the crowd I just love putting
Haskell slides in my code because it
makes me happy
Haskell yes whoa next problem so problem
number three sort array by parity give
it an array a of non-negative integers
return an array consisting of all of the
even elements of a followed by all of
the odd elements of a you may return any
answer that satisfies these conditions
so yeah I've heard about you know 10 to
20 people once again the algorithm that
solves this exactly is did partition so
when you want to sort basically your
array or a vector by a predicate which
is just a function that returns a
boolean you can just pass that as the
third parameter here so the first two
parameters are iterators defining the
range and then our third parameter is a
predicate in the form of a lambda here
checking whether we have an even number
and so those will get put at the front
and a little about visualization of this
algorithm is the following so you put
basically an iterator or an index at the
front of your array and then you put one
at the back and then you're gonna look
for an element so if we want to put all
of the the pink elements at the front so
we want to basically partition so that
the pink or at the front blue or at the
back we want to find a block that fails
to meet our predicate at the front and
one that passes at the back and then
swap those and continue to do that so
with the iterator at the beginning of
the array we're gonna look for a blue
block we're currently not at that so
we're gonna step one to our blue block
here now we have a blue block so we're
gonna go to the end we're gonna try and
find a pink one we're already at a pink
one so now we just swap these two and we
continue to do this so once again we
find a blue one at the beginning then we
want to find a pink one at the back we
swap these and you're done
so this is going to be a linear runtime
algorithm used to be my favorite
algorithm before I discovered in a
product /transform reduce if you're not
familiar with those go check out the
prequel to this talk so this is actually
mentioned previously at meeting C++ Ivan
Yvonne
- kitch pointed out that this
implementation is something that's
called the two-finger method where
basically you can put a finger here and
a finger here and go so he gave a
fantastic talk I believe it was called
compile time type transformations
that'll be online in a couple months and
if you're watching this on YouTube it
probably already is online I highly
recommend going and checking out that
talk and this once again is the Haskell
solution note that Haskell there
partition algorithm returns a tuple or a
pair so you have to sort of append those
together to get the default behavior of
the C++ sto partition moving on to the
next problem given an array nums write a
function to move all of the zeros to the
end while maintaining the relative order
of the nonzero elements so I think all
of the same people that yelled o
partition just yelled oh it's stable
partition so this is the exact same
algorithm that we just saw but as you
saw from the implementation
visualization you're not guaranteed that
the relative order of the elements in
each of the partitions are maintained if
you need that requirement stable
partition is the algorithm to reach for
so very nice and once again this is the
Haskell solution note that the default
partition that comes with Haskell is a
stable partition so nice to know and
last but not least for chapter one is
the final problem number five which is
the most difficult of the five that
we've looked at so K closest point to
origin we have a list of points on the
plane which is a Cartesian plane oh
whoops I guess I did not add that and
find the K closest points to the origin
0 0 here the distance between the two
points on a plane is the Euclidean
distance note that there's a couple
different measures we're concerned with
Euclidean and that's sort of the
Pythagorean formula if you're familiar
with that and you may return the answer
in any order and the answer is
guaranteed to be unique no partial sort
so that is an algorithm that can solve
it an nth element is also one so there's
actually three algorithms that we can
use to solve this
the first one is stood sort so we can
start all the elements and then we are
gonna pass it basically a comparator in
the form of lambda that's calculating
the Euclidean distances and then
comparing them and then at the end with
the return statement we're just using a
vector to return the first K of
elements so this is gonna be an M log M
solution where n is the number of
elements in our array but this is not
optimal as someone showed it up from the
back we can do one better than this but
before we look at that algorithm is
there a small optimization without
changing the algorithm that we can use
to make this better yes so we can drop
these square roots because we're still
maintaining the comparator so there's a
coming from the crown that the standard
library function high pot is actually
what we want to use here which I'm not
familiar with but I will check that out
afterwards
but this still definitely works so
moving back to the solution that was
shouted up from the back of the crowd
partial sort is actually much better
than what we had before here so here
we're just passing now a third iterator
in between the iterators that define the
beginning in the end of our range and
it's only now gonna sort basically the
first or the top K elements based on the
comparator that you pass it and so the
only thing that's difference between
sort and the partial sort is that single
iterator with the plus K which is really
really nice and then is mentioned by a
few people in the crowd we can do one
better than this
with nth element and note that the only
thing we've changed there is the
algorithm named partial sort and element
so what are the two differences between
this and element is a partial sort that
basically gives you the top K elements
but not in sorted order so if you have a
partial sort and your code reviewing you
should ask yourself do I actually need
these K elements at the top to be sorted
if not you can change what I believe is
an N log and worst case but it's gonna
be like K log K in most cases for
partial sort you can change that to a
linear runtime algorithm which is
fantastic
so I think most C++ veterans know about
this but I've made this mistake you know
in the last couple of years where I've
written a partial sort even tweeted it
out and then someone said why are using
partial sort you can use an element and
then you know did a facepalm and yes so
very important to know and that brings
us to the first sort of relationship
that I'm pointing out in this talk is
that when you have any of the first two
ask yourself if we need a full sort if
not switch that to a partial sort and
then ask yourself do we need those K
elements partial sorted if not switch it
to an nth element so at this point we
are going to look at another clip from
the same talk that we saw earlier from
Kate Gregory where she said the
following
partials or copy she does what it says
on the tin it gives you a copy a smaller
collection that is just the things that
would have been at the front and it
leaves your original collection in its
original order you don't want to sort
your vector this is not the right name
for this I'd like to see it called top n
I am delighted it is there that we
should had another name do not tell me
to write a paper so Kate Gregory is
saying that partial sort copy has the
wrong name it's very unintuitive and it
should be called pop m I don't agree
she explicitly said that we don't want
to sort our elements we just want the
end top elements what she's talking
about is an algorithm that doesn't exist
and element copy what she's describing
should be called top and sorted and
we've made this mistake before where
we've we've had an out we've had more
this isn't an algorithm it's actually a
data structure that implicitly is sorted
and then it's led to the MIS naming of
another data structure map and said by
default our map and set are sorted and
that's something that a C++ developers
we need to you know cash in our brain in
Python it is the opposite their set is
by default the hash set because it
doesn't have that extra sort of you know
piece of information that isn't there
and if you want a sorted set or a sorted
map you have to go to a different
library in the collections called sorted
collections and it's called sorted set
and sort of maps so I I completely agree
with Kate Gregory with respect to one
thing and that is that naming is very
hard and that was the name of her talk
so we've seen eight eight algorithms is
so far up to this point and they're all
listed here on the screen two of these
don't rely on
stood swap shout it out if you know the
two for each is one of them and
transform is the other one so these six
algorithms all rely on stood swap and so
if you played this game with me last
night when we were out please refrain
from answering but if we switch for one
of these algorithms the stood swap to a
stood move
make one other minor change we get
another algorithm does anybody know
which algorithm it is enlisted in pink
and what's the resulting algorithm all
right you can answer now if you remember
from last night remove if and stable
partition so stable partition relies on
stud swap and it basically puts elements
that satisfy the predicate at the
beginning and fail at the end remove if
does the exact same thing but instead of
doing a swap it doesn't move and leaves
the elements at the end in an
unspecified state the only thing to note
is that technically the elements that
satisfy the predicate are the ones that
are you know moved from in or left an
unspecified state so you have to put
like a knot in front but this is the
second relationship so if you have a
stable partition and you actually don't
care about the second partition you can
switch that to a remove if and improve
your performance so this is a neat trick
as well so moving on to chapter two
these problems are all solvable by two
STL algorithms so we're upping the ante
now this is gonna be a little bit more
difficult so our first problem squares
of a sorted array give it an array
integers a sorted a non decreasing order
return an array of the squares of each
number also sorted a non decreasing
order you might be thinking this is very
simple but we have to look at the notes
and note that number two says basically
we can have values between negative
10,000 and 10,000 the note here being
that we could have negative values so
shout out if you know either one of the
two or if you know both you can shut
them out to solve this problem transform
is one of them and stood sort is the
other one so yes I had a comment from
the front row could it be done quitter
quicker there are a couple algorithms
that can be utilized to sort of do some
merge and then not sorting the full
array but for the purposes of this we're
gonna stick with this solution so doing
a stud transform like we saw in the
first chapter and then calling a sort at
the end so pretty straightforward moving
on to the next problem Oh actually I've
done this pole now and this will be the
last time I do this pole who prefers
that so there are two different formats
here where we have base
this vertical format and this horizontal
format and I've been checking with
different audiences so raise of hands if
you prefer the first vertical format and
hands down who prefers this format that
was maybe 2 to 1 or 3 to 2 in favor of
the vertical format so I think across
all the conference's that I spoken at
people have said for at least 4 slide
where the vertical format is a bit more
readable but it was actually trick
question
you note you shouldn't have answered
this is the format you prefer the C++ 20
ranges it's basically doing the same
thing and in the future once everyone's
upgraded to C++ 20 we should all just be
writing our code like this so yes now
now moving on to the next problem after
we look at the Haskell solution which is
obviously much more short and beautiful
and makes everybody happy so finally n
repeated elements in a size 2n array
this is the original problem previous
times I've asked this it's led to a lot
of discussions so I have simplified it
to element element repeated once and the
problem states in an array a of size n
there are n minus 1 unique values there
for exactly one of those values appears
twice returned the value that is
repeated two times you only need to
return it once so what is the value that
exists in this array that appears more
than once and note that this isn't a
sequence this isn't 1 to 10 and then
we've duplicated one of those elements
this is just random values so there's a
mathematical trick you could use if what
I just said was true but that's not true
these are just random values so two
algorithms to solve this problem shut it
out if you think you know one of them
sort is one of them and adjacent find by
Jason from the front row is the second
algorithm that is correct so if you sort
one of the properties of a sorted array
is that all equal elements will be next
to each other and there's an algorithm
called adjacent fine that basically
looks at adjacent pairs of elements and
applies a binary predicate to those two
elements and returns true if it
satisfies that predicate and the default
binary operation that comes with
adjacent find is stood equal to so out
of the box we can use adjacent find to
solve this problem
so there's a comment from the back
called why not use unordered set I
should have mentioned that we're looking
for an employee Lucien and a none so
ordered set would be more efficient you
do it in linear time but you would also
be required to allocate so it's a great
point but for the purposes of these
problems we're trying to do all of the
algorithms in place so moving on I think
we have the Haskell solution here I'm
not going to talk about this but it just
it looks so beautiful I think everybody
agrees so I believe this is the the last
problem of this chapter and it's one of
my favorites of this talk so it's a
medium level problem so getting a little
bit more difficult the problem is
entitled search in a rotated sorted
array so suppose an array sorted in
ascending order is rotated at some point
a pivot point unknown to you beforehand
so note that if we start with 0 1 2 4 5
6 7 if you do a stood rotate I think at
the 4th point you end up with 4 5 6 7
and then 0 1 2 so we're going to
simplify this for the next line and
basically it's asking if you find the
target value that you're given return
true otherwise return false and you may
assume that there's no duplicates and
the final requirement of this problem is
that you need to have a log n solution
in terms of time complexity so I've
heard rotate I've heard lower bound
lower bound is closed
I heard adjacent fine and sort those are
both wrong I heard the right one which
I'll state in a sec and what do we do
after so that I'll say it now so the the
first correct algorithm is partition
point and what do we have to do after
that binary search so before we look at
partition point which is probably an
algorithm that people are less familiar
with as I was before you know preparing
for this talk we can solve this first in
linear time using an algorithm called is
sorted until so that's going to give us
the basically the point in our
partitioned vector or array where it's
been rotated at and then once we have
that point we can do one of two binary
searches basically searching the first
partition if we know our target value is
greater than the first element because
then we know do the fact that it was
originally sorted it's gonna be in the
first partition otherwise do the binary
search in the in the second partition so
that's what the last line does
unfortunately is sorted until is a
linear runtime algorithm at which point
I typically say does anybody know an
algorithm that is does this in log n for
the problem here and as stated by me how
this algorithm is partition point so
typically people know at least three
maybe four login algorithms in the STL
algorithm header those being binary
search lower bound upper bound and the
fourth one is equal range which actually
if you were just in Bjorn follows talk
he mentioned two of those algorithms but
there's a fifth log in algorithm that
most people are unaware of and that's
partition point so basically it does the
exact same thing except it has a unary
predicate and it's looking for where the
left element returns true for the
predicate and the right element returns
false for two adjacent elements so if
you're in the first partition both of
them will return true if you're in the
second partition both of them will
return false and at the partition point
you'll get one true one false so this is
a really really nice algorithm to do
basically finding a partition point of a
partitioned algorithm so super super
nice and we can simplify this lambda in
the middle here depending on your
opinion I'm not sure if this is
simplified using stood behind and stood
greater equal which is really really
nice and this code makes me extremely
happy so partition point for the win
remember it is log in Chapter three so
I'm going to talk even more about
Haskell now saying as this is a c++
conference Haskell engineering so we're
gonna talk about how we can use Haskell
to help us understand you know C++
better and so this starts by looking at
the Four Horsemen of a user group that
is in the Pacific Northwest of America
called the Northwest C++ user group and
the Four Horsemen of this group in my
opinion are the four individuals so all
four of these people used to attend this
user group so the first two are Andre
Alexandre SKU and Walter Bray who are
associated with which language deal
anguish so Walter Bright's the creator
and Andre Alexandre SKU is one of the
top contributors May
the Top Contributor now I'm not sure
Eric knee blurs the third individual he
is the individual behind ranges v3 and
is helping you know get ranges into the
standard and the fourth individual is
Bartosz Milewski Bartosz Milewski used
to be in the c++ topia but now has
migrated to Morbihan haskell and has
written a very very popular book called
category theory for programmers and
Bartosz Milewski said on a podcast
recently the following alright he didn't
say it yet so first thing I'm gonna show
is a clip of Oden Holmes talking about
people leaving C++ to go to functional
programming languages I mean I've seen
this with my friends to this kind of
behavior where as soon as they start
dabbling in functional programming they
they don't really come back right and
and the reason for this is obviously
that the functional programming so I'm
sure most of you know as I've seen it
shown it previously this is the Haskell
logo and and bartosh has given a ton of
talks at this same conference in
previous years that basically talked
about you know category theory and sort
of putting Haskell asked stuff in C++ so
this is a quote from one of the podcasts
that I just or so this is a quote from
Bowden home saying as soon as they
dabble in functional programming they
never come back and this is the list of
the talks that bartosh has given I
highly recommend you guys go check this
out if you're interested in functional
programming and are a C++ developer and
now is the quote by Bartosz Milewski
from the podcast that I recently
listened to it's a way so understanding
functional programming was like a
shortcut for you to be able to
understand template metaprogramming
yes yeah being able to think in Haskell
but write in C++ was your advantage yes
it was programmers saying that even if
you program in C++ it's a good idea to
learn some Haskell and then a couple
second laters a couple seconds later he
said this if you solve your problem
first in Haskell and then you translate
it into C++ you will probably get better
quality codes so I'm not sure I
completely agree with that in all cases
if you write something in Haskell and
then you know translated into C++ you're
gonna end up with higher quality code
but I do think that the exercise is is
is very valuable and that you can learn
things and have insights about STL
algorithms and other things in C++ by
doing this so that's exactly what we're
gonna do this is a problem that I showed
in the prequel to this talk I'm gonna go
through this pretty quickly if you're
interested in sort of the full-blown
solution and how I walk from an
imperative solution to a STL algorithm
solution refer back to the original talk
but very quickly this problem states the
following so it's entitled trapping rain
water and it says given n non-negative
integers representing an elevation map
where the width of each bar is 1 compute
how much water it is able to trap after
raining so if you treat each of the
black bars basically defining a
mountainous range and remove the blue
the questions asking if it were to rain
how much water with this mountainous
range catch and originally I show the
imperative solution but this is the
algorithm solution and the idea is
basically that you are first identifying
where the maximum is and then you're
gonna do something called a max scan
from the left and a max scan from the
right so scan in C++ 17 is an algorithm
called inclusive scan in C++ 11 it's
called partial sum so basically in
partial sum you're calculating the
partial sums at each point in time of
all of the elements from the start of
your range to the current index that
you're at but you can overload the
binary operation that comes with partial
sum which is + to be anything that is a
binary operation so in this case we're
using you fo max which is basically
going to then give you the partial max
at each point in time up until the
maximum so once you've done this and you
have your sort of scan max array this is
going to define this black and blue
range so once we have that range if we
just subtract the original range the
black from it we're going to be left
with the blue so that involves first
taking the max element then doing two
inclusive scans one from the left to the
maximum and then one from the right to
the maximum which we're doing that with
reverse iterators and then we do a
transform reduce at the end to basically
take the difference between these two
ranges with the stood - that's our
transformation binary operation and then
we do a reduction to add all the Blues
up to get a single number so if I went
through that really quickly in your
thinking that was
confusing the point of this problem
isn't to understand the solutions like I
said look back to my prequel talk if you
want to understand this better the point
here is to just note what are the three
algorithms that we're using to solve
this problem
max element inclusive scan and transform
reduce so remember those three
algorithms now we're gonna look at the
Haskell solution and compare the
algorithms that we use in the Haskell
solution to these three algorithms so
here is the beginning of our Haskell
solution the first thing that we need to
do is to find the maximum of our range
we're gonna just do that by calling an
algorithm called maximum fantastic then
we're gonna find the index of this
maximum using a length and take while
then we're gonna split our array into
basically two partitions we're gonna do
that with a take I which is taking the
first il iment s-- and then doing a drop
I which is dropping the first I elements
and then we add those two together
while doing a scan from the left to the
max and then a scan from the right to
the max and that gives us Y so YS is our
basically black + blue and X's is just
our black so now what we have to do is
just subtract those two and we do that
with a zip with - and then we add all
those up with a sum so once again you
might be thinking this is extremely
confusing I don't understand this at all
that's okay I'm assuming most people
aren't you know Haskell enthusiasts here
or actually raise a hand who is
considers themselves a Haskell notice I
see like three or four hands so yes most
people aren't here but once again what
we're trying to compare here is just the
names of the algorithms so there's a
couple optimizations we can do first if
we want to do a take and a drop there's
an algorithm called split at that
basically does it does exactly that and
pattern matching is built into the
language here so we can split a and B
right at the point when we call split
out which is wonderful and we can now
combine split at and take while into an
algorithm called break which is
fantastic so you end up with this really
really concise beautiful piece of code
in my opinion and at this point we're
going to compare the C++ STL algorithms
to the algorithms that we see on screen
here so first we're going to start with
inclusive scan everyone can probably
point out where the inclusive scans are
the scan L and the scan are on the
bottom so you can see here these are
these basically parody what we saw on
the C++ solution the next album
algorithm that we're gonna try and find
is Mac's element I'm sure everyone once
again can point this out as maximum but
now we're left with transform reduce
and so I've heard some zip so there is
no single algorithm on the board or on
the screen that basically matches our
transformer dues but what is transform
reduce it's just a composition of two
algorithms one's a reduce and one's a
transform so can anyone point out what
algorithm is the reduce sum and that
leaves us with transform but previously
I said that the equivalent of transform
in Haskell was map so how could that be
the case so these are the two type
signatures of zip with and map we can
sort of align these a bit align them a
bit more switch the colors and what
we're showing here is that C at the end
is the return type for our function so
we have this type signatures what they
call it in a Haskell it's the equivalent
of a function declaration in c++ and for
map we have a single unary operation and
a list of a as our parameters and we end
up with a list of C's and for zip with
we have a binary operation that takes an
A and a B and gives you a C and then
takes two ranges a and B and gives you a
C both of these are stood transform in
C++ and I think this is incredibly
important to cache in your brain if
you've seen Jonathan Picard's talk 105
algorithms in an hour
he sort of mentions this that the two
range version of transform is often
neglected and I completely agree and in
other languages they don't call them the
same thing they're completely different
things because in the two range version
there's an implicit zip which I've
talked about previously my prequel talk
we're not calling out the fact that
there's an as if in an algorithm a lot
of the times leads to people miss
appreciating it or under appreciating it
so the point here is cache in your head
stood transform is both map and zip
within functional programming languages
and if you can cash this in your head
you'll start to use stood transform a
lot more often so that brings us to
chapter four we're going back to lead
code and I believe the first thing in
this chapter that I'm going to point out
is not attach to a problem because I
wanted to reduce the amount of time of
this talk but it's the following thing
here that if you have a find if you can
upgrade this to a lower bound or an
upper bound and once again if you were
just Symbian followers talk he did this
exact thing where he showed a find if
and then pointed out oh wait we have
elements that are sorted so we can
actually use a lower bound or upper
bound here and this was also mentioned
by Shawn parent in his C++ seasoning
talk that's a find if maybe you might
think implies that this stuff is sorted
well if you read the actual function you
would find that yes in fact everything
except for the item we're looking for is
in sorted order and now we can replace
the find if with a lower bound and we
can do a binary search for that guy so
incredibly important another thing to
add to your code review of algorithms if
you see a find if ask yourself is this a
sorted array or descending array or sort
of by some sort of comparator if so you
can replace your find if and go from
linear time to login time which is
fantastic so this brings us to the only
problem of this chapter and it's by far
my favorite from the talk and it's
actually pretty simple
so it's entitled reverse only letters
and it says given a string s return the
reverse string where all characters that
are not a letter stay in the same place
but all the letters are reversed in
their positions so this is a little bit
you know complicated to visualize if you
don't have an example so this is the
example we're given one a B to CD and
note that the one in the two because
they're not alphabetic letters stay in
their same positions but the ABCD are
reversed so you end up with DC and BA so
the question I'm gonna ask is how many
algorithms do you think we need to solve
this chapter one was one chapter two is
two I'm not saying anything about the
pattern here so we're gonna go through
raise of hands who thinks you can solve
this with one algorithm zero hands who
thinks you can solve this with two
I see about 10 to 20 who thinks you can
solve this with 3 probably less than
that or maybe it was 10 10 or so and
then who thinks you can solve this with
4 I see zero so we only had votes for 2
& 3 and most people are not voting so I
guess they just want to wait and see so
we're gonna start with 3 so shout out if
you think you have one of the three
algorithms that can be used to solve
this no one--not reverse is one of them
and copy if is one of them and stood
transform is the other one so basically
what we do is we do a copy if it's a
letter and then we put that in a string
called letters then we do a reverse of
that string letters and then we do a
transform where basically we we loop
over or map over our original string and
any time we encounter a letter you do a
copy from our string our string letters
and then we just increment basically an
iterator that's pointing at the current
letter in our string letters and then we
continue to move that along every single
time we visit a letter so basically
we're copying all the letters reversing
them and then copying them back into our
original string in order to get our
result so does anybody know how we can
remove one of the three algorithms on
the screen in order to do the exact same
thing that we're currently doing which
which algorithm can we remove yes we can
remove reverse and then basically just
do copy if with reverse iterators so now
we're down to two algorithms so if you
said three unfortunately you're
incorrect but can we get down to one
does anybody know an algorithm that
currently isn't in the STL algorithm
header that we could use to solve this
in a single line close it's an if but
even less generic than transform if what
we want is reverse if
unfortunately we don't have this
algorithm but I thought oh we're giving
a talk let's go and you know implement a
very naive incorrect version of this and
and see if we can get the the correct
behavior for at least the the test
samples that were on this website so a
sample implementation might be the
following note I'm not asking to point
out bugs
there's tons of bugs on the screen this
is just supposed to be illustrative to
how this algorithm might work so you
have to iterators one at the beginning
one at the end and you're going to have
an outer while loop that basically while
these two iterators are not pointing to
each other you continue and then you
have two inner while loops that
basically at the beginning are checking
you know while we're not pointing to a
letter continue to iterate and then we
do the exact same thing at the end while
we're not pointing to a letter decrement
and then we just swap those two once we
find them and we continue to do this
until the outer while loop exits so a
more you know correct version but still
incorrect is the following algorithm but
the point I want to make here or the
question I want to ask is who knows an
algorithm who has a very simple or
similar implementation compared to this
I heard it make sure you come and get a
candy afterwards partition so we saw
this visualization earlier to iterators
and basically we're trying to find a
blue and a pink and then swap them so
blue at the beginning pink at the end
and then swap them for this algorithm we
want to do almost the exact same thing
but instead of finding a blue at the
beginning in a pink at the end we want
to find two blue elements and then swap
those so basically here we're finding
two elements that satisfy the predicate
we're looking for and then swap them so
here we step once we step once again and
then we swap we continue to do this we
find a blue at the back swap these and
then we're done and then at this point
we have reversed all of the letters or
the the elements that satisfy our
predicate for our algorithm so can we
use stood partition to solve this
problem the answer is yes so here in our
lambda we're basically capturing and
initializing a boolean flag B equal to
true
and then anytime we start at the front
any time we get an element that then
satisfies that predicate we then toggle
that boolean so that when we go to the
back we're basically putting a knot in
front of the predicate in that fantastic
and I went check this i actually
submitted this code on li code and it
worked it passed I'm not sure I would
recommend this code because it it it
basically relies on the implementation
of partition being exactly what I showed
if it's anything different it's gonna
break but MSV see and I believe clang
both do it this way so ya wouldn't write
this code but it's an interesting trick
to note that not just by sort of the
names and the behavior but also by the
implementations can we draw dotted lines
between algorithms it's very very neat
and this made me extremely happy when I
discovered it I went on like a you know
hour jogging had to you know burn off my
excitement cuz it was it was so awesome
so that's fantastic so the comment from
the crowd was I would also expect thrust
partition to work Oh a bet it would not
work that's not that the opposite of
fantastic then that's true yes yes so
the comment on the crowd is that it's a
paralyzed for parallelized version so
obviously it doesn't have the same
implementation so nobody was correct cuz
nobody said one in the past I think one
and a half people were correct in
meeting C++ but yes awesome observation
so last but not least the final chapter
of this talk is the Shon parent game so
this is a super fun to play along so
basically the way it's gonna work is I'm
gonna throw an algorithm up on the board
and you guys have to shout out or
everybody here has to shout out which
algorithm we can use to implement this
one algorithm so does anybody know what
algorithm that's very similar to is
sorted that we can use to implement is
sorted
yes so I heard mostly a different
algorithm which we're gonna talk about
just in a sec but the one that I'm
looking for is is sorted until so is
sorted until gives you the element that
you know is no longer in sorted order
and so if we are returning basically the
past the last element iterator we know
that our whole array or vector or data
structure is sorted and if we go and
check the MSV see implementation of is
sorted there's a lot of noise here but
the only thing I'm pointing out is that
sure enough is sorted is implemented in
terms of is sorted until so that's a
very nice thing to know so coming back
to is sorted until a bunch of you just
shout it out what's an algorithm that we
can use to implement this adjacent find
yes so a bunch of every one or a bunch
of people previously just shouted this
out so we can use adjacent find to
implement is sorted until so note that
we covered this before
it looks at adjacent elements if we
overload the binary operation to be less
than or equal to we then can basically
get the same behavior as is sorted until
and I believe I have a couple
implementations from MS VCF is sorted
until up on the board and then next is
adjacent find note that it is sorted
until is not implemented in terms of
adjacent find but this is toggling
between them they're very very similar
they're not identical but they're very
similar so let's let's do a diff so on
the first line it's just the algorithm
name so we can ignore that on the third
line it is just a comment so we can
ignore that too on the very last line
it's just basically doing an assignment
that is using different variable names
so we can ignore that one as well and
then on the third from the bottom
it's just incrementing a little bit
differently so the only line that's
actually different is the one that's
comparing the predicate and it's a bit
hard to see but the only difference is
the order of which the elements are
passed to this binary predicate so
basically you can implement is sorted
until exactly in terms of adjacent fine
but just by flipping the order in which
the elements or the arguments are passed
to the binary predicate and we can make
use of this really nifty flip function
from the boost HANA library that was
written by Louie Dionne who I believe
met two
so called out previously in his talk at
code dive so this is super super nice
and it's an it's a neat trick so we're
back and this is where it gets fun does
anybody in the crowd know an algorithm
that we can use to implement adjacent
find and the reason it's called the Shan
parent game Shan parent went straight
from is sorted until to this algorithm
it's not rotate and I also want to call
out when I was at meeting C++ last week
this individual has been the first
person to go from adjacent fine to these
algorithms so still not at the Shan
parent level but he's the only person
that I've spoken to that has been able
to get this algorithm and in my opinion
these are his he's the founder of the
Italian C++ community and the
corresponding conference and he has a
blog where he talks about tons of
algorithms and he had a whole are a
whole article on this algorithm which is
what leads me to believe that he was
able to get this so so find if is close
and the one other thing I'll add is I
might have said this before this is in
my opinion the worst named algorithm
across all of memory algorithm and
numeric you're getting close so inner
product was another guest that was close
so the part that makes inner product
close is that it combines two ranges the
part that makes find if close is that
it's short circuits
stood mismatched so stood mismatched is
an algorithm that takes two ranges
returns you a pair of iterators to the
first pair of elements that satisfy or
fail to satisfy the binary predicate
that you provide it with and by default
stood mismatches given equal to so here
we're gonna look at the first two
elements they're equal second two are
still equal third two are still equal
and then the fourth are not equal so
it's going to return you a pair of
iterators pointing to these two elements
and so in order to implement adjacent
find we can basically do the same zip
tailed trick where we pass at the 0 to n
minus 1 and 1 to n elements so that
you're comparing adjacent elements and
that's all you need to do and I
originally wrote this code and my local
Meetup and then Michael Park fellow
Canadian pointed out that in C++ 17 we
added a function to do exactly what
we're doing here so all we're doing is
basically applying a knot to the
predicate that we we were passed in and
so we can just use stood not fun which
does this exact thing so then we end up
with this extremely beautiful code
so Michael Park thank you for pointing
that out
I think this algorithm should be called
zip fine technically stood mismatch is
zip fine not there is a there's a knot
inside but if we take that knot outside
and then we could just implement stood
mismatch in terms of zip fine by doing
the exact trick that we just saw some
people might argue that we should call
this transform find because we want to
you know maintain parity with our
transform and transform reduce
algorithms but I would argue that the
transform fine that takes a single range
isn't really that useful you can do that
with find if and that we should just
leave it called zip find and it only
takes two ranges so a sample
implementation of zip find would be the
following or
sample invitation of mismatch in terms
of zip find would be the following we're
here we're now applying the not fun C++
17 function and then we could have
implemented a JSON vine in terms of zip
find where we don't need to do any of
the sort of double negating in order to
get the behavior we want and so note
that for adjacent find we don't want to
return a pair of
we only want to return the first of the
two iterators which is a super super
neat trick and so I went and took a look
or so we're gonna talk about the
algorithms that all have these implicit
zips so we just talked about mismatch
there are three other algorithms that
one of them I mentioned previously and
the Haskell solution and a couple others
so shout it out if you know the
algorithms that have an implicit zip so
transform yes that is the zip with inner
product and transform reduce these at
least for the two range versions can be
thought of as zip reduce and there's a
fourth one I count inner product and
transform reduces the same equal which
takes two ranges and just returns you a
boolean and whether they're equal to or
not you could implement this in terms of
zip reduce with a logical and for your
reduction and an equal to for your
transformation but I actually went and
checked to see how is equal implemented
this is the MSB see they're not
implementing it in terms of anything but
I did find this implementation that
implements equal in terms of mismatch
which is not what I had initially I
thought it's the transform reduce that
we wanted but this individual
implemented equal in terms of mismatch
any guesses who this individual was what
was that nope not STL
Alexandr Stepanov for those of you that
don't know he is the father of STL and
the original implementer so very neat
piece of knowledge note that he didn't
do it vertically this is how he
implemented it this is my sort of
formatting but yes so equal can actually
be implemented in terms of this
mismatched checking whether the
iterators are pointing to the end of the
ranges and there's several other
algorithms here that all take two ranges
but they're not implicitly doing zips so
try not to get those confused and yes
mismatch in my opinion it's the worst
named STL algorithm the second worse is
adjacent difference which I think should
be called adjacent transform and these
are all the algorithms that we've
covered in the last hour here note that
there's a few of them that are grayed
out there's a 90 minute version of this
talk that I might give at some point
which covers the other ones and yes last
but not least is the conclusion so in
Chapter one we covered the relationship
between sort partial sort and an element
and remove if and stable partition in
Chapter two we've recovered the
relationship between is sorted until and
partition point and pointed out that
partition point is the fifth and log in
algorithm for chapter three I pointed
out that transform is both zip with and
map and functional programming languages
which I think is important to cache in
Chapter four I covered how you can
upgrade find if two lower bound and
upper bound and how partition can be
used to implement reverse if asterisks
don't really do it and in Chapter five
the relationship between is sorted is
sorted until adjacent find and
mismatched and last but not least for
those of you that are from row Slav you
might have recognized that on each of my
chapter title slides I had these little
photos those are all from wrote Slav so
if you're not local from here and you
have a couple extra days to check out
the Christmas market I highly recommend
going and checking out for long because
it's an extremely beautiful city thank
you
you